んはぁああああ
今日は外れそうです皆さんはーヘアー
好きですかあの僕ですねー
部屋が大好きなんですよ部屋というものは人にとって特別な空間
自分だけのいらし車の中とかすごいな自分だけの部屋なんて一人ぐらいつも自分だけの
実家にはない自分だけど
それは秘密基地とか作りませんでしたそういう感覚なんですよね
自分だけの部屋が欲しいなと思ったんですけどもうネットで見てたら組み立てられる
ヘアが売ってたんで買ってみましたうずらです女に雇われクソでっかいですね
これね閉じこもることが出来れば欲しい音が小さい体が空間だ一つ欲しいなって思って
この部屋で健吾ヒロインですよガラッとしててやれよねここらへんにねこううんこれに
大きなフェアを作りたいんですよでな皆を驚かずに聞いてくれ
この部屋何度ダンボールで出来るみたいですそれがしっかりした部屋作れるっぽい
キュッ
でもの初めは見えずベッドワークにもう一つ新しい部屋を作りたいと思います
じゃよこーよ
[音楽]
0大先輩良い作ります
あとも作りが全くバカな待って出稼ぎん
なんでこんな選んでくれて聞いてねーぞこれまずいがいざプレイ酒ます
[音楽]
へえへえええええ
何って本当にでかいんだこれえっ
します
いいねこれを組み立てて凶器かちょっと見てみましょう
何か簡単って書いてあった気がすんだよな全然入らない
これも入れないなんだこれお礼も多分入らないのかなー方法
とりあえずこれを開けてよとして部屋に入るみたいな感じなんじゃないや晴れ
作りたいこれは絶対ドアなんだな
まあカッコここに言っで個人的ダンボールボス弾ボッツ
もう捨てなんすよねほんとねどんだけ覚えたしもう大丈夫なんじゃないか説があるん
ですけど
手順がですね10個あります10個余裕だな
刺激度10個でいるチョパーティー行っちゃいましょう床パンで寄せ
に置きますですってわかった
だめーナマズで本当にデカすぎてヤバいここからなんですけどここにいる
これだけがするんですよねうんこれでおいてを組み立てていくみたいなイメージだと
思うんですけどただもうこれさしていけば出来る気がするんだよね
[音楽]
やばいん
一人で組み立てになって書いてある俺一人だと無理音ですね必ずしたり以上で組み立て
てくださいって書いてあります
ja
赤ちゃん嘘です赤ちゃんみたいだって赤ちゃんに
[音楽]
me
ます
ん
1番だった
もう一1ですこれでん座ったっての早いっすよ1時間家庭で作るの
よし
はい1いうわけで完成
a と思いきやまた天井が残っていました
あとココですねここだけです
あってこれ天井いるけど要らない気が急くだけど
くらいじゃんって100パーセントくらいじゃんにょ天井ページをつけなきゃいけない
んですけどさと暗そうなんで取り外しがいつも出るようにこの申しております
相手受けて完成しましたあの
すげーじゃんいや邪魔とは言いませんが場所取りますね
もうこの部屋の方なんかすげーするわけだしちゃった気がしますまあそれはあるでしょ
でかいんですけどねんかねぇゲーム実況とができそうかなーと思ってですよ僕は防音
でしょだってちょっと中に入ってみました
はい行きます
あ
おーまてくらあ調べて暗いぞ店長物を空けた方がいいのかんじゃなかったらなかった
なあ坊の意味がなくなるんですけど開けると大体これぐらいの明るさになりますと言わ
れてここにこうやってパソコンだおいてね編集したり勉強とかもここでできるっていう
感じですこれあのダンボールの中ですけどけっこう広いじゃ全然動かせるからだがなあ
と
俺もような10%増をつけるかどうか暗くのれから中に何か正面を渡っつけないといけ
なくなるんですけどいいなぁ
普通に電車が嬉しいだんぼっちでまずちょっと印象あるですけど真ん中今後ゲーム実況
とか猫失礼何が使うときとかに使えればいいなぁかなと思っております
めっちゃ嬉しいけど部屋がクソ狭い
[音楽]
me
ni
あっはぁ